[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم
الحقيقه اول زمايلكم
محمد
يعني
ساعدت جدا لان عارف
مدى اهميه الاسره
وعارف ان
كنتم
بتهدوا صوره طيبه وجميله
للجامعه وده شيء يسعدني جدا
الحقيقه
انا اتكلم
من غير ورق لكن الورق
بس
عشان انا مجهزها
هي كلمه من قلبي
وناسه موجوده
دلوقتي
محمد
والغرض الاساسي اللي بتشوفه نماذج
واذا كنت هتعذروني مثلا لهذا
انا اقول والخص الدنيا
انا عارف ان عندي وقت محدد لازم التزم بيه
التجربه بتاعتي كانت مبنيه على
تلات حاجات
الحاجه الاولانيه
انك تخصص احد عامل النجاح
تانيه
ان الرضا والشكر
هو اساس
التالته
اللي ما احبش اعمل تفرج احب اعمل من خلال
مجموعه
لازم يكون المجموعه وانتقام اهلا وسهلا
باذن الله
فده تلات
حاجاتهم قدام عينيا
تلات حاجات
ممكن يعني يكون
مثالي لحضراتكم
انا اساسا طبيب بشري اتخرجت باسيوط
الحمد لله
هو ممكن اقول لبعض ولادي التسلسل الطبيعي
لاي حد عشان في الجامعه جدا من معيد مدرس
مساعد ومدرس الدكتوراه استاذ مساعد واستاذ
المفروض بعد الاستاذ ياخد منافق اداريه
انا بقى كان
معظم
اتجاه المعين هل هو بيتجه يكون اعرض
الطلاب
الدراسات العليا ولا يجمع
اتجاهات اخرى
انا هي كان دايما بتكون ناحيه كلها
ابتدت النيول دي تظهر قوي
بعد ما خدت المدرس التراب اللي كان اول
خطوه انا حاليا كنت ساعتها
باسيوط معين بس اتنقلت بعد كده
خدت من الشيء ودكتوراه مدرس ابتدى بقى
يعمل اكبر كان اول حاجه عملها رئيس جامعه
يدي له الصحه
عمل اسره اسمها اسره المتوقين تشمل الطلاب
علميا ولا شرطيا
واختارني انا لسه بدرس
الشباب زي الطور هيثم كده والدوران
ان انا اكون انا رائد اسره المتفوقين هو
مستوى الجامعه
وكنت فعلا دي اول نشاط واضح
الحمد لله نجحنا الاسره
خدت دائره بسرعه
كنت اوجد واحد مساعد الطلاب
امريكا اكبر صعوبه وهي ان كانوا في اقبال
على الولايات التمريض انتوا عارفين الصعيد
وكانت كليه التمريض ان البنت تخش كليه
التمريض يعني الى حد ما مش ايه
الحمد لله نجحت
ان ابتدات عليها اخباره غير طبيعي انا اول
وكيل لكله التمريض
جامعه المنيا
نقلت الحمد لله المشروط الطلاب
كليه التمريض كان بتطلع رقم 15 وعدد كليه
جامعه المنيا اتنقلت من 15 رقم خمسه
بعديها كم سنه الحمد لله خدت استاذ
وطويله بعديها مباشره
انك تتخصص في الحاجه تحبها هي تحبك بتديك
قعدت تقول الطب نقلتها
في الترتيب من المركز العاشر للمركز الاول
على مستوى جامعه المنيا
حبيت
الموضوع بجانب انتقائي للفريق اللي بيشتغل
معنا ونشتغل كفريق ما اشتغلش محمد مصطفى
بالضبط تلات سنين
لان منصبعه المفروض ما يتولعش اي بني ادم
غير بعد خمس سنين للاستاذ
انا خدت استاذ 2000
2005 او سته
لشؤون الطلاب
ده اللي بقول للولادي
حب حاجه هتحبك وتديك
استمرتنا في الطلاب خدت مده كلها
رجعت لفتره بعد كده رئيس قسم
2016 وانا هنا
نائب رئيس الجامعه رسوم الطلاب
حتى وقتنا
بشتغل مع فريق الحقيقه جميل جدا
سواء على مستوى العمليه الوكلاء
بشتغل مع مكتبي وفرصه اشكر استاذ رضوى هي
موجوده معي انا بتطلع معاها وامتنان احمد
كمساله
والحمد لله دائما بيكون معا
ها وغيركم الاسر
يعني اقصد انك
اشتغل كفريق تنجح
لو اعتمدت على امكانياتك الشخصيه فقط
هتنجح شويه لكن
في جامعه المنيا عشان تعرفوا عزيزه الطلاب
او الطالبات بالذات
اول مره جامعه المنيا تستضيف حاجه اسمها
اسبوع الشباب الفتيات على مستوى جمهوريه
مصر
اسابيع الشباب بتعمل اسابيع عامه لاولاد
وده العالم لكن انك تعمل فتاه على مستوى
على مستوى مصر بتعمله في جامعه المنيا
وعملنا اسبوع هايل يقعد فيها طبعا الوزير
وكان الله مبارك ساعتها كان عايش كله
ونجحنا نجاحا الفتيات طالبات
وبرجع اقول للهاتف الاساسي انك تتخصص في
الحاجه وتحب الحاجه ما تشتت روحك
استمر بقى الكلام ده لما
جيتلها او مشاكل الطلاب ما اقدرش اقولها
مشاكل ولكن
بنحاول نحل حاجات كتيره فيها
من الحاجات اللي بعتز بها قوي وان انا
بحاول احلها
يمكن بعضكم
مرت بهذا المشاكل زي المشاكل الاسكان بعد
الطلبات الاسكان مشاكل معينه ولكن تبقى
المشاكل دي محصوره
ما بين المدير الاسكان وبين مديرك مكتبي
ما بيعرفهاش حد شخصيه
[موسيقى]
حاجات تانيه
الموضوع البصمه موضوع الجداول الامتحانات
بالتعاون مع الكليات لدوله التدريس
الانشطه الطلابيه
اعتقد يا احمد
طلبت المعظم هنا طلبه العلاج ولا في تلك
طيب هو بس انا بتكلم على الرحلات ده اكتر
حاجه بيحبها الاولاد والطالبات
شكل مختلف
وعاوزهم دلوقتي واحنا دلوقتي
[موسيقى]
في رحله
طبيعي اكتر
اسالوهم دلوقتي
مدى فرحتهم والرحله النهارده اخر يوم
ما كانش في البرنامج خالص
الرحله قدها
قالولي نفسهم يروح بس
ده يزيد عن تكاليف الرحله المعتمده
على طول ويروح
يتمتعوا عشان ما دام هم مبسوطين الجامعه
مفيهاش هدف غير يكونوا مبسوطين بس يكونوا
في التزام بعض رحله وفعلا وولاد علاج
الطبيعي والكلام ده عن شرط اذا كان تم ده
فمن اسبوعين
وفي رحلات الدمنه التانيه خلال هذا النوع
الرابع
حاجه منهم بورسعيد وحاجه تانيه برضو ده
برضو لكن
دايما كده انا كل شويه ابص عشان التزم
دلوقتي
ان تخصص
نتخصص في حاجه ده شيء مهم جدا انك تشتغل
من خلال المجموعه بشيء مهم جدا
ما تشتغلش في الفرد
ملخص حياه البني ادم هيبقى صعب قوي انك
تروح تاخده ربع ساعه لكن انا بحاول اجتهد
والم كل خبراتي معكم بس جمعتها لكم في
نقاط سريعه او عشان ندي فرصه يتكلموا تاني
حاجه عشان تشوفه كمان الخبرات المفترجه
انا عندي خبرات في مجال شؤون الطلاب ممكن
غير يجيبوا خبرات في مجال الابحاث
والدراسات العليا
بشكره دائما هيعمل كل الحاجات
وعندنا الفريق عمل هايل
هاي مجموعه ممتازه
انا قبل ما اقول الحلقه الثانيه بقى ان
الحقيقه
بنوعيه خاصه
مختلف لكن انتم متميزين بنوعيه خاصه
من ضمن الحاجات برضو حاولت نجددها هو مركز
الدعم الاكاديمي اللي بيتابع التجاره
المتعصرين
الصيدله وحاليا مش شغالين على
من ضمن الحاجات برضو اللي قابلتني مشاكل
فيها وما زلنا بنحاول نحلها الناحيه
النفسيه
في مركز
واعتقد عن المحاضره هيتكلم ممكن يتكلم
فيها مركز الشد النفس يبقى فينا شكل كتيره
منحاول على قد نقدر نحلها بالتعاون ما بين
طور نبغه والدكتور طارق النفس اللي موجود
دي الحقيقه مشاكل وصعوبات مش هنقدر نتكلم
عنها ان حاجات بتبقى خاصه لكن بامانه يا
اولاد بتمثل
وحاجات مش موجوده
سواء اذا كان مركز الدعم الاكاديمي اللي
بيقود عبد الناصر او مركز ارشاد النفسي
اللي يقول النبا تحت اشراف مكتبي
الحاجه بقى اتكلمت عن الناحيه العمليه
الناحيه الشخصيه
انا لخصت عشان البنات الموجودين يعني
ينطلقوا وهيكون الدكتور محمد اخي
الرزق بتاع
الدنيا
كتير منه انك ترزق ببنات وبترزق باولاد او
ترزق بالاتنين
احيانا الاختبار يكون لك بس
انا من الناس دي
في الصعيد
لكن هنا جت في الحته الرضا الشكر
رضا والشكر لما ترضى تشكر ربنا يكرمك انا
اتمنى كل البنات الموجودين يكونوا زي ما
انا عين
اربعه بس انا
توام
واحده
استاذ مساعد
هما كانوا بيفتكروا بيا
الوقت انا اللي بفتخر
اتمنى كل بناتي
يكونوا احسن
ده نتيجه ايه الرضا
الشكر
اللي شكرته لازيدنكم
انا بشكركم في الاخر الاشتماع بدون وقتكم
واتمنى اكون ضفت حاجه لكم
واي حاجه تقابلكم كأسره اي
حاله اقدر اساعد فيها مش هتاخر عنك ابدا
اكرر شكري لكل الناس اللي فاهمه بنجوم
وقرر شكري
احمد
اولادي رضوى كل الناس الموجوده
اشكركم جميعا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]